On Friday.
I'm going to talk about Joe Biden's recent
campaign strategy, if you can even call it
that, of sort of laying low and not being
super public.
But today I want to update you about polling
since it's been about a almost two weeks since
I last did and it's actually more bad news
for Joe Biden, Joe Biden's polls keep dropping.
We're going to put the trajectory up on the
screen for our video audience, and the story
has been that before announcing his candidacy,
Joe Biden was pulling around the mid twenties
up to the high twenties and then eventually
Joe Biden announced and said, I'm actually
running for president, and that spiked up
to higher than 40 support for Joe Biden.
But since then it hasn't been so good and
there's been a regular trailing off of Joe
Biden.
Last time I talked about this, Joe Biden's
polling had trailed down to about 35 or 36%
and the last week has seen more drops to an
average of between 33 and 34% for Joe Biden.
Now a quick note here before we continue the
analysis, if you never believed that Joe Biden
was polling as high as he was a month ago
because the Poles were supposedly fake, which
I don't believe, right, but if you believe
that, then you should also not believe that
Joe Biden's polling has been trailing off.
It's sort of weird to see the same people
that say the polling is totally fake.
Now site the polling as evidenced that Joe
Biden is losing support.
Uh, it's one or the other.
You can't have it both ways.
It's like Trump saying the employment numbers
are fake under Obama, but they're real under
him and an indicator that the economy is doing
really well doesn't work.
Okay, so don't do that.
But in any case who has been gaining from
Joe Biden's polling drops up.
Bernie Sanders has seen a slight uptick into
the high teens.
Elizabeth Warren has seen a very small uptick,
but most recently it's actually been Pete
booted judge who has been climbing in the
polls and very slightly Kamala Harris, a lot
of people are still just going nowhere.
I mean Tulsi Gabbert continuing to pull about
half of 1% unable to get it to move.
Jay Inslee, Tim Ryan, John Delaney, Bullock,
Gillette brand, Williamson, they can't even
get to 1%.
Um, but there have been two sort of major
opposing views on the Biden drop and what's
causing Biden's decline.
One view is Biden staying out of the public
eye is hurting him because people are forgetting
about them and people aren't supporting him.
Because there just aren't aware of his presence.
The other view is that since Joe Biden publicly
announced more people are understanding his
platform and they don't like it.
And thus people who thought, oh, well I kind
of liked the idea of Biden.
It's sort of reminiscent of the Obama era
as they learn about Joe Biden's platform.
They are moving away from Joe Biden either
or both could be true or neither depending
on who you're talking about, which part of
the country you're talking about.
But in the immediate, the question becomes
the debates and Iowa being the first primary
or caucus.
Uh, the reality is that Iowa depends on relatively
few voters and Biden is still doing well in
Iowa, although he is trailing off there in
the same way that he has been nationally.
Here's my advice to you, if you don't like
the way this primary is shaking up, uh, in
terms of the people that are getting more
attention, in terms of the people that are
leading the polls, to the extent that you
believe the polls and generally I think the
polls are a pretty good picture of what's
going on.
Don't get mad at the Poles and the fact that
a candidate you don't like might be leading,
okay campaign for and be an activist for whoever
you think is the best candidate period.
And soon the debates, we'll start and we'll
start to get a sense of whether the numbers
move, we'll start to get a sense of how people
who are going to be voting in the Democratic
primary are actually reacting to these candidates
in real time, particularly not just to their
ideas but to how they relate to other candidates
that are on the stage.
The reality is that historically in general,
in June of the year before an election, which
is where we are now, this is like June of
2015 relative to the 2016 election.
This is like June of 2011 relative to the
2012 election, June of 2019 in the context
of the 2020 election.
The polls are pretty good at telling us who
is likely to win the nomination.
Historically.
We'll see if something is different this time
around.
Uh, but that is a reality that we have to
contend with and we have to accept at this
point in time.
Generally speaking, the winner of the primary
is going to be someone who is already polling
relatively well.
It doesn't have to be the number one person,
but it's extraordinarily unlikely that it
is going to be someone who's pulling below
two or 3% at this point in time.
If you disagree, let me know.